(crowd cheering)
- All right.
Everybody, we have reached
the end of the hour,
but I have one more story
that celebrates the 1980s.
This is "What I'm liking."
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
So meet Laken.
Since she was little,
her family's told her
she looks just like her grandma.
So for fun, Laken recreated
some of her grandma's old photos,
complete with into chair and clothing.
So let's see the results.
This is Lake's grandmother,
and this is Laken.
It's amazing.
(crowd cheering)
Let's do it side by side.
That's amazing.
And here's another.
I mean, it's kind crazy.
Okay. Let's see one more.
Right.
(crowd clapping)
It's like uncanny.
So Laken surprised her grandma
with the photos for her 71st birthday,
and she loved it, obviously.
We have Laken on the line now who watches
on WBBJ TV in Jackson, Tennessee.
What's up Laken.
(crowd cheering)
- Halo.
- [Kelly] So looking at your background
I feel like you're already
rather into vintage.
(crowd laughing)
- Oh, absolutely.
My whole existence is vintage.
I own my own vintage shop
and make a pottery inspired by vintage.
So that's kind of how
all this came together.
I knew my grandma's
birthday was coming up,
and so I called my grandpa.
I said, you have to send me photos
of grandma from when she was my age.
I have the perfect gift idea.
So he sent me about a dozen and I'd say,
the hardest part about all that
was getting the hair, the makeup,
and then thrifting the outfits
as close as I could to the original.
And then, so it took my
friend, Evelyn and I,
about five or six hours to the hair,
the makeup, outfit changes, and editing
all of the in the videos
to get them just right.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
(crowd cheering)
It's such a rad gift,
what a cool gift idea.
Your grandmother's reaction was adorable,
so what did she say to you after?
- She's just so tickled.
We all are.
She's just shocked by the amount of people
who have seen our faces. (laughs)
We cannot believe all the
positive support online.
These photos are more than
me just looking like her,
but her seeing herself in
someone that she loves so deeply,
and feeling seen and appreciated.
And I think that's exactly
what this video did
and the support online day for her.
(crowd cheering)
- Wow. You are one of my favorite people
I've had on this show.
You are so cool, and
that was so beautiful,
what you just said.
That was so sweet and sincere.
Thank you so much Laken for
not only sharing this with us
but doing that for your grandma.
That's such a cool thing.
(crowd cheering)
- Thanks.
- [Kelly] And I love your vibe.
I wanna be you, Laken.
Okay. I'm liking your post right now.
- [Laken] Okay. (laughs)
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] All right. That's not all girl.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pin makers of Frixion,
the go to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am, and creating sweetly,
they're gonna give you a
$1,000 just for being cool.
How about that?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh. (laughs)
Oh my gosh.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] All right.
Have a good day. (laughs)
(crowd cheering)